hello and welcome to this video playing
a plus k inertia monster a plus k so
isn't that the guy no that's a different
person right and places d3 stuff all the
time I'd say it's a different guy I'm
sorry confusing him with someone ok we
have a Italian game check this line yeah
night BTW to this is an interesting game
medline and i have not yet studied its
own this looks like you will probably
have some good shines the same wow this
is compensation wow it's hard to believe
I really don't know I mean I know that
this is a viable gambit but I have
absolutely no idea about the details I
mean here what initial reaction is i'm
just a pawn up for absolutely nothing
okay it's got some pieces to achieve it
you said really um you said really
dangerous Queen age for I have not G 695
maybe Nyjah 5s is something nice you
wakies active this active but is that
really enough solidify this little bit
83 okay so we just place this position
upon down so G for coming and
okay it's clear that this is technically
not at all easy but still it's an ending
with an extra pawn so what to do
probably double and Toby's to go behind
the schoo 4 p-6
he's got this the deep hdporn is also an
issue currently wants to take and takes
his six there should be 70 hours a
little bit a little bit passive
Jim not so happy with the smooth it's
very difficult I want to go to get
forward this is not at all easy to do
hmm look at four nights takes it I
Bishop d7 95 with the temple
it's also not easily play about him okay
b6 was wrongly timed yeah that was a
badly badly timed badly timed decision
b6 yeah it's a real shame this is a
completely incorrect gambit that you
played they have the way it turned out
but i didn't i didn't manage to to do
something good against it check your
problem is time warning hi bishop my
bishop is completely incarcerated yeah
yeah just wants to trade now I'm playing
without this bishop what then what did
what a royal mess that I put myself into
here I cannot take but I cannot avoid
the chat tape trade either but what did
whatever what a completely dropped a
game that I played here might be six MOS
bad was just bad and now he can he can
go 96 he gets all the time down and he
will be much quicker and 96 wins yeah
now that was a very very bad game black
resides which is pretty yeah it's a bit
disgusting because he's just a pawn down
absolute
nothing in I mean you can just play to
hold this position with the good night
but I mean losing the blackest is
completely completely out of yeah it's
just totally bad I should I just should
not play be 60 it would be difficult to
win this position for sure the night is
just very strong but you should never
ever ever ever lose of course and okay
you can argue about the trade in the
first place but and about 96 m I mean
you can we can maybe say I should get
more all of this like Bishop here first
98 96 and so on yeah it's just a pawn up
for nothing okay I can hope to hold but
b6 was just terribly bad bad timing this
helps him enormously yeah he gets to
play on the weaknesses and it's just I
would like to return the pod but I don't
really see how I was thinking rue care
for but I don't relieve I don't I don't
see a movie as a thing like Bishop d7
comes with the temple yeah I have to
already limit the damage after if I have
played b6 let in really see how and I
mean okay this looks terrible but I just
didn't see something good and now i am
at say five or six this is a terrible
position absolutely terrible yeah the
engine doesn't understand how bad it is
it gives zero but the position is
probably losing for black am playing a
bishop down you'll hear their engine
recognizes the problem but yeah also
this is just now i cannot play this
position bishop is sorta eight
it's really totally ridiculous that b6
is bad I mean this is really the thing
if I don't play b 6i can never lose but
it's possible that night g6 is a bad
decision because it gives why this cop
out that he shouldn't have I mean you
just see just place a flat porn down in
this position and here at least his
night gets gets a good square yeah but
tell me that was some so quite
instructive to see and that beasted b6
was a really bad decision here I have to
try to improve first and then I can see
em if I can do something here to use
that pole on the queenside it seems very
unlikely because of the strong a bind
that this night has but yeah at least I
cannot be worse if I do it correctly
okay well thanks for watching